salut il ya quelques temps michael hirsh
qui était déjà passé sur la chaîne et
qui fait des vidéos qui s'appelle
lettres ou ne pas l'être m'a proposé de
faire un feat avec lui d'aller tourner
une vidéo avec lui sont des vidéos
particulière c'est la première fois que
je fais une vidéo comme ça et je me suis
dit qu'il y avait peut-être un intérêt à
vous faire voir les coulisses de ce
tournage
alors là je suis prêt je vais me taper
meaning de métro entière et je vous
emmène avec moi je suis un petit peu
moins seul
la première étape d'un tournage ça
commence souvent par une heure de métro
et là je viens de dire la ligne 3 et ça
y est je suis enfin au bout d'une heure
et demie d'arriver chez michael hirsh
alors si ça vous parle pas je vous mets
un insert tout de suite c'est exactement
ça son décor et en plus c'est pas du
tout un insert puisque puisque je suis
dans le décor directement voir là par
exemple je peux vous dire que ça c'est
en 3d ça existe réellement regarde je
peux toucher le c'est un chat ou un
chien c'est un chat un chat
c'est un chat dire que je trouve en
trouvons un nom trouvé un nom pour le
chanony cayir je vous pouvez me dire
dans les commentaires
quel nom vous voulez qu'on donne aux
chats michael hirsh alors pour vous
remettre un petit peu le truc en
perspective quand michael m'a proposé de
faire la vidéo battu parle j'étais ravi
évidemment et et il a cherché le thème
de la vidéo et tu as décidé que c'était
la mémoire et quand il a décidé que
c'était la mémoire on a longuement parlé
au téléphone oms a appelé plusieurs fois
et on a passé des minutes voire des
heures à discuter de la mémoire ensemble
et au delà même de la mémoire ou des
trucs que je peux donner sur la mémoire
dans les vidéos ou ailleurs
là c'était vraiment notre rapport à la
mémoire j'ai pas encore découvert tout
le texte
je vais découvrir ça et le rôle que
j'aille jouer et voilà comment ça se
passe un feat on arrive et on sait pas
tout et j'ai hâte de découvrir
quand je vois les accessoires je suis
stressé donc quand même avant de tourner
ce serait bien que j'en sache un petit
peu plus mais je voulais garder avec moi
pour que vous voyez ce que ça donne un
brief avant un tournage
donc on est sur un être ou ne pas l'être
classique avec toujours les deux plans
et avec le personnage intermédiaires et
c'est ce personnage là que moi je
voudrais que tu fasses 57 tours la
lettre ne pas l'être c'est une lettre
sur la mémoire ça tu le sais ans
a parlé ensemble et du coup j'ai
vraiment axé la lettre on ne pas l'être
sur le rapport qu'on a à notre mémoire
et le rapport un peu conflictuelle qu'on
peut avoir entre mémoire et technologies
je te propose d'incarner un jedi oublie
wan kenobi oblige kenobi une autre angle
le son de ma voix
c'était qu'à demi mot oui c'est vrai
nous la limite a fait naufrage et gère
un featuring de série d'experts et c'est
le texte que tu vois là bas exactement
et alors l'idée c'est qu'en fait cette
lettre est un peu particulière parce que
je trouve que les basses et dire qu'on a
un rapport à notre mémoire qui est un
comme une sorte de rapport de couple ok
c'est à dire qu'on a vraiment quelque
chose de très intime entre nous et notre
mémoire et l'idée c'est de dire que
petit à petit à cause des nouvelles
technologies eh ben on se perd un peu de
vue et en s'éloignant
et du coup c'est une être et à s'étendre
et je vais pas dire triste mais un peu
mélancolique et du coup ce que je
trouvais assez drôle c'est que ce
personnage d'oubli wan kenobi ils soient
assez martiale pour justement cassé et a
mené à un truc un peu comique là dedans
est vraiment qu'on est une surprise à
chaque fois qu'il apparaît main et c'est
vraiment dur je t'avais prévenu tu le
savais quoi faire exactement c'est c'est
bien oui donc en fait c'est plus qu'une
campagne c'est que lui s'impose comme
dans quelqu'un qui a des pouvoirs une
vraie relation avec toi et que tu vois
tu la dénigrer qu'aujourd'hui se dit
mais tu l'as cherché aussi quoi tu vois
exactement c'est à responsabilité sur
ses longs avec en fait ben alors couler
ça ok et donc je suppose que j'ai obtenu
un oui tu as un un peu cynique tu
préfères tu préfères être oublié wan
kenobi 2
plutôt que je joue bach a par exemple
c'est vrai tu vois premier guest de la
chaîne de michael et je suis super
content parce que je voulais que fabien
soit le premier guest de la chaîne du
coup c'est cool parce qu'il a accepté
cette vidéo et ça me fait bien plaisir
je sais que là ils se disent ah ça doit
être pour la vidéo non je m'habille tous
les jours comme ça et pour la première
fois je le dévoile voilà c'est pour
passer incognito dans la rue maintenant
il se déguise en jedi
vous n'avez pas vu cette vidéo
j'aimerais qu'on prenne deux secondes
pour analyser ce qui vient de se passer
michael est en train de réduire le
tabouret parce que je suis trop grand
parce que je suis trop grand cercle
depuis le début de l'année on à la
raison je suis petit mais on a la preuve
je suis trop grand pour ça je suis
content d'être venu
moi ça me suffit tiens à voilà parce que
j'étais trop lent